Cette épreuve de dissertation,
elle fait vraiment peur !
Déjà,
elle dure CINQ HEURES !
Et puis
il n’y a pas vraiment de programme…
Ça calme,
n’est-ce pas ?
Bon,
du coup,
vous avez VRAIMENT INTÉRÊT
à connaître LES RÈGLES DU JEU
de cette épreuve.
Moi,
je les connais bien,
parce que j’ai préparé
les concours de la fonction publique
pendant deux ans ;
MAIS SURTOUT
parce que,
CHAQUE ANNÉE,
je prépare des candidats
à la dissertation de culture générale
du concours de l’ENM
— « l'École nationale de la magistrature
»,
si jamais vous ne connaissez pas
cette école.
J’ai même commenté ENTIÈREMENT
une copie
qui a été notée 15
sur 20
à ce concours
— vous trouverez facilement la vidéo
sur cette chaîne YouTube.
Dans CETTE vidéo,
je vais vous dire TOUT
ce que vous devez savoir
pour préparer
l’épreuve de dissertation de culture générale
du concours de l’ENM :
les modalités À JOUR
de l’épreuve
(je dis « à jour »
parce qu’il y a eu des réformes) ;
les caractéristiques
des sujets qui peuvent tomber ;
et enfin,
la notation
et les résultats aux concours.
Alors,
c’est important de connaître tout ça,
mais vous savez
ce qui est plus important :
la MÉTHODOLOGIE
de la dissertation !
Ça tombe bien,
j’ai ce qu’il vous faut :
profitez de mon cours GRATUIT
de méthodologie de la dissertation.
Vous pouvez vous y inscrire
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant en haut à droite
de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description de cette vidéo.
Les élèves qui préparent le concours de
l’ENM
l’adorent,
donc je sais
que vous ne serez pas déçu.
Mais bon,
vous ne regardez pas cette vidéo
pour que je vous parle de méthodo.
Rentrons donc dans le vif du sujet :
QUE devez-vous savoir
sur l’épreuve de dissertation
de culture générale
du concours de l’ENM ?
Pour commencer,
il faut préciser une chose :
il ne s’agit plus exactement
de « culture générale »,
car l’épreuve s’appelle désormais :
« Connaissance
et compréhension
du monde contemporain »,
ou CCMC.
En effet,
l’épreuve a été modifiée
en 2009
dans le but d’améliorer
l’égalité des chances.
Il s’agit désormais
d’une « composition portant sur une question
posée aujourd’hui à la société française
dans ses dimensions judiciaires,
juridiques,
sociales,
politiques,
historiques,
économiques,
philosophiques
et culturelles.
»
Ouh là,
on a le choix !
L’enjeu de l’épreuve
est donc assez clair :
c’est de montrer
que vous COMPRENEZ
le monde contemporain
à travers une question
posée à la société française.
L’idée,
derrière,
c’est que vous devez connaître
le CONTEXTE D’INTERVENTION
du magistrat.
Quant à L’ÉNUMÉRATION
de toutes les dimensions de la réflexion,
elle signifie que vous devez mobiliser
des connaissances transversales,
exploiter des supports variés,
et faire des comparaisons
(européennes,
internationales).
Donc vous êtes libres
de mobiliser divers types de connaissances
:
vous pouvez bien sûr
citer les références de culture générale
incontournables
pour les concours administratifs
— j’ai d’ailleurs publié une vidéo
dans laquelle je vous donne
une liste de vingt références —
donc vous pouvez citer
ce genre de références,
MAIS vous pouvez aussi citer
des décisions de justice,
des rapports ;
vous pouvez parler d’économie,
de la vie de l’administration
— vous pouvez parler
de plein de choses.
MAIS à deux conditions.
La première,
c’est que vous réussissiez
à inscrire votre réflexion
dans une histoire LONGUE.
Les sujets sont certes plus orientés
vers les questions contemporaines
depuis 2009,
mais l’épreuve RESTE
un exercice de culture générale
dans la mesure où on attend de vous
un grande AMPLEUR de vue.
OUI,
la question est contemporaine ;
MAIS votre analyse,
elle,
ne doit surtout pas
se limiter à l’actualité,
ou à l’histoire récente.
D’ailleurs,
les rapports de jury reprochent aux candidats
de trop se raccrocher
à l’actualité immédiate
de la vie politique française.
La SECONDE condition
à laquelle vous pouvez mobiliser
des connaissances transversales,
c’est de les mobiliser
AU SERVICE DE LA RÉFLEXION.
Ça c’est une autre dimension
des réformes les plus récentes
du concours de l’ENM
— celles de 2009
et de 2019.
En plus d’améliorer l’égalité des chances,
ces réformes veulent décourager le bachotage,
et repositionner l’épreuve sur la vérification
des capacités DE RAISONNEMENT.
Regardez ce que dit
le rapport de jury de 2019 :
« La reprise de plans et fiches préétablis
est particulièrement NÉGATIVE
et ne peut abuser des correcteurs de multiples
copies.
»
Ça confirme
ce que je répète
dans toutes mes vidéos :
la dissertation N’EST PAS
un contrôle de connaissances,
mais une épreuve
de RÉFLEXION
et d’EXPRESSION ÉCRITE.
Voilà voilà,
je vous ai dit
l’essentiel à savoir
à propos de l’épreuve.
Ce que vous devez retenir,
c’est que le sujet portera
sur un débat ACTUEL
de la société française ;
que vous pouvez
et DEVEZ
mobiliser
une grande diversité de connaissances ;
MAIS que vous devez le faire
AU SERVICE de la réflexion,
et que vous devez démontrer
une profondeur d’analyse.
Allez,
on regarde les sujets !
Bon là,
on va être pragmatiques :
on va lister les sujets tombés
depuis 2009,
comme ça on pourra se rendre compte
de leurs caractéristiques.
Sur le plan de la formulation,
on voit qu’il y a
TROIS TYPES de sujets.
D’abord,
les questions.
Ça représente quarante pour cent
des sujets.
Le deuxième type de sujets,
ce sont les « notions »,
entre guillemets.
Je dis « entre guillemets »
parce que « l’eau »,
par exemple,
ce n’est pas vraiment une notion.
Mais bon,
vous avez compris :
ce deuxième type de sujets,
c’est juste un mot
— comme « Fraternité »
tombé en 2020,
ou « la démocratie »
tombé l’année précédente.
Depuis 2009,
ça représente un sujet sur quatre.
Enfin,
le dernier type de sujets,
ce sont les locutions,
c’est-à-dire des groupes de mots.
Depuis 2009,
ça représente un tiers des sujets.
Comme vous l’imaginez,
un sujet de dissertation
posé sous la forme d’une question,
ça ne se traite pas de la même manière
qu’un sujet
qui consiste en un seul nom commun
— comme « l’eau »,
par exemple.
Ça,
c’est une chose que j’apprends
aux élèves de ma formation avancée
à la méthodologie de la dissertation.
Voilà pour la formulation,
intéressons-nous maintenant aux THÈMES
des sujets qui sont tombés.
On peut déjà remarquer que,
comme le voulait la réforme de 2009,
le caractère CONTEMPORAIN
de la question
est important.
Ensuite,
les thèmes sont assez divers
depuis 2009 :
l’égalité des chances,
le rôle de l’État,
la confiance,
les frontières,
L’EAU,
l’identité,
la violence,
etc.
— j’arrête là,
parce que ça change chaque année.
S’il y a peut-être un thème GLOBAL
qui revient plusieurs fois,
c’est la cohésion sociale,
le vivre-ensemble :
en 2011,
en 2014,
en 2018
et en 2020.
MAIS BON,
ça change quand même
chaque année,
donc c’est difficile
de prédire le sujet.
Autre remarque :
grosso modo DEUX TIERS
des sujets
sont plutôt PRÉCIS.
Par exemple,
celui sur les frontières,
celui sur l’eau,
ou encore
celui sur le terrorisme.
Ça veut dire que vous aurez besoin
de connaissances précises,
ou bien
que vous devrez être assez HABILES
pour traiter un sujet PRÉCIS
MAIS SANS AVOIR
de connaissances précises.
Il existe des techniques pour faire ça,
et je les enseigne également
dans ma formation avancée
à la méthodologie de la dissertation.
Voilà,
on a analysé
les sujets tombés depuis la réforme de 2009.
Vous devez vous souvenir
de TROIS CHOSES.
PREMIÈRE chose :
le sujet sera
soit une question,
soit une seule notion,
un seul nom commun,
soit une locution
— et il n’y a pas vraiment
un type de formulation
qui est plus probable
que les deux autres.
DEUXIÈME chose
à retenir :
le thème change
chaque année.
Et enfin TROISIÈME chose :
le sujet est souvent PRÉCIS.
Allez,
il est temps de parler
de la notation
et des résultats.
Alors tout d’abord,
qui seront vos correcteurs ?
Des juristes,
principalement du public.
Voici par exemple
la liste des membres du jury de 2019.
Regardons maintenant
les notes.
Les rapports de jury disent
que les résultats sont comparables
d’une année sur l’autre.
Ces dernières années,
les correcteurs se tiennent
à une grille de notation
pour être les plus objectifs possible.
Comme dans beaucoup de concours,
une bonne partie des copies
sont notées entre huit
et dix.
C’est le « ventre mou » :
ce sont les candidats
qui n’ont pas RATÉ
l’épreuve,
mais qui n’ont pas bien traité le sujet.
Concernant les moyennes,
ces dernières années
c’est entre 8,5
et 9,5
pour le premier concours,
c’est-à-dire celui des étudiants.
Les ADMISSIBLES
ont en moyenne douze,
ou un peu plus de douze,
tandis que les NON ADMISSIBLES
tournent autour de huit.
Ça veut dire
que si vous voulez vous fixer
un objectif SIMPLE
pour être admissible,
alors visez AU MOINS
DOUZE.
Concernant le deuxième concours,
celui des agents publics,
et le troisième concours,
celui destiné aux personnes
qui veulent se reconvertir,
passer du privé au public
— concernant ces deux concours,
les moyennes sont grosso modo
entre un
et deux points inférieures
à celles du premier concours
— c’est-à-dire
que ça tourne autour de 7,5
8,5.
Les ADMISSIBLES
ont en moyenne onze,
ou un peu plus de onze,
tandis que les NON ADMISSIBLES
ont en moyenne entre six
et huit.
Ça veut dire
que si vous voulez vous fixer un objectif
SIMPLE
pour être admissible à ces concours,
alors visez AU MOINS
ONZE.
MAIS il est possible
d’avoir de très bonnes notes.
En 2016,
la meilleure note était 17 ;
en 2018,
18 ;
et en 2019,
17.
Après,
ces notes
sont forcément rares.
Si vous voulez regarder les statistiques
DANS LE DÉTAIL,
elles sont à À LA FIN
des rapports de jury
— mais je vous conseille
de ne pas perdre votre temps
avec les statistiques détaillées,
ça ne sera pas rentable pour vous.
Pour finir,
je vous rappelle LES COEFFICIENTS
de l’épreuve.
Depuis 2020,
l’épreuve de « connaissance
et compréhension du monde contemporain »
a un coefficient de quatre
sur un total de dix-sept,
ce qui veut dire
qu’elle compte pour
23,5 pour cent
dans votre moyenne d’admissibilité
— ça fait presque
un quart.
Ça veut dire
que si vous avez douze
plutôt que huit,
ou bien seize
plutôt que douze,
vous gagnez UN POINT
dans votre moyenne générale.
Et qu’est-ce qui fait la différence
entre un douze
et un huit,
ou entre un seize
et un douze ?
Ce n’est pas la culture générale,
parce que vous n’allez pas devenir Jacques
Attali
en un ou deux ans
— non,
c’est LA MÉTHODOLOGIE
qui fera la différence.
Je vous conseille donc de vous inscrire
à mon cours GRATUIT
de méthodologie de la dissertation,
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant en haut à droite
de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description de cette vidéo.
Allez,
c’est l’heure de conclure !
Alors,
qu’est-ce que vous devez retenir
de cette vidéo ?
Pour faire simple,
retenez trois choses :
vous devrez réfléchir
à une question qui se pose ACTUELLEMENT
à la société française ;
ensuite,
les formulations
et les thèmes des sujets
VARIENT,
mais les sujets sont souvent PRÉCIS ;
et enfin,
pour être admissible,
visez PLUS DE DOUZE
si vous passez
le premier concours,
et PLUS DE ONZE
si vous passez
le deuxième ou le troisième.
Et encore une fois,
la clé pour réussir cette épreuve,
c’est LA MÉTHODOLOGIE.
Voilà voilà,
j’espère que cette vidéo
vous sera utile.
Je suis Romain,
je suis toujours avec mon fidèle Haristote,
et vous étiez
sur 1000 idées de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous que n’avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête
pour réussir
la dissertation de culture générale
au concours d’entrée de l’ENM.